y
[Música]
la agencia europea del medicamento de
anuncios que no se han identificado
efectos secundarios para la vacuna
desarrollada por facer beyond tech y
ésta no estaría vinculada con ningún
caso de muerte tras la inyección
mientras tanto la comisión europea
publicó ya el contrato con astrazéneca
pero sin datos sobre el volumen de
entrega
en américa latina sólo siete naciones y
están vacunando pero sus campañas
avanzan a paso lento mientras los casos
y muertes siguen en aumento en la región
méxico superó en fallecimientos a la
india y ya es el tercer país con más
decesos en el mundo en perú hubo
protestas contra los nuevos
confinamientos y bolivia recibió su
primer lote de 20 mil vacunas rusas y
sputnik
la irrupción de nuevas tecnologías
facilitó la coordinación de un golpe
masivo contra fondos de inversión y que
causó pérdidas millonarias en wall
street ante el frenesí especulativo
alrededor de las acciones de empresas
como game stop las aplicaciones que
ofrecen a pequeños inversores la
posibilidad de participar en el mercado
de valores
anunciaron restricciones un trato
calificado de injusto e inaceptable por
algunos congresistas estadounidenses
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' de todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria también venidos continúa el
enfrentamiento entre la unión europea y
astrazéneca por los retrasos anunciados
en la entrega de las vacunas acordadas
para el primer trimestre del año la
farmacéutica dijo la semana pasada que
sólo podría suministrar alrededor del 40
por ciento de las 31 millones de dosis
previstas en este periodo sin embargo
este viernes se anunció que suministrará
al menos 8 millones de dosis más la
agencia europea del medicamento aseguró
que la vacuna de facer bayón tech no
está vinculada con ningún caso de muerte
posterior a la inoculación entretanto la
comisión europea hizo este viernes
publicó el acuerdo con astrazéneca tras
los problemas de entrega de su vacuna en
la unión europea un documento en el que
sin embargo están ocultos el número de
dosis a distribuirse cada mes
se suponía que ayudaría a la unión
europea a acelerar su campaña de
vacunación pero ahora se ha cuestionado
la efectividad del fármaco de
astrazéneca justo antes de que el
regulador del bloque esté listo para
probarlo los funcionarios de salud
alemanes han recomendado que no se
administre el medicamento a personas
mayores de 65 años
sabemos desde el otoño ya que este
debate se ha presentado durante varios
meses que con astrazéneca hay menos
datos de estudios con grupos de mayor
edad no se trata de datos malos sino de
poco en aldeas con gates en respuesta
astrazéneca defendió su vacuna al igual
que reino unido que la ha estado usando
en el programa de inmunización masiva en
el país durante semanas
nuestras propias autoridades han dejado
muy claro que piensan que la vacuna de
oxford es muy buena y eficaz
creen que es eficaz en todos los grupos
de edad
la farmacéutica anunció la semana pasada
que no podría entregar los 80 millones
de dosis esperados a europa en el primer
trimestre citando inconvenientes de
producción en una planta en bélgica sin
embargo este viernes dijo que ofrecería
8 millones de dosis adicionales al
bloque los retrasos en la entrega han
enfurecido a la unión europea pero las
dos partes prometieron trabajar juntas
para resolver el problema
méxico reporta más de un millón 825 mil
casos confirmados y más de 155.000
muertos por el coronavirus con esta
cifra rebasa a india en el número de
decesos un país con una población diez
veces mayor y a pesar de no estar entre
los 10 países con más contagios méxico
se ubica entre las tres naciones con más
muertes en el mundo detrás de eeuu y
brasil hasta el momento se han aplicado
en territorio mexicano casi seiscientos
cincuenta y ocho mil vacunas el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien padece la enfermedad se encuentra
prácticamente asintomático según la
secretaria de esa
seguimos con información latinoamericana
porque bolivia recibió su primer lote de
20 mil vacunas rusas y sputnik para
inmunizar al personal de la salud que se
encuentra en la primera línea de lucha
contra el kobe 19 el presidente luis
arse participó del acto para recibir las
vacunas en el aeropuerto de la ciudad de
el alto que sirve a la paz bolivia ya
rebasó los 210 mil contagios y las 10
mil muertes
y en perú el gobierno del presidente
interino francisco sagasti anunció
recientemente nuevas restricciones y
cuarentenas para lima y otras nuevas
regiones del país desde finales de enero
hasta el 14 de febrero pero un amplio
sector de la sociedad se opone a las
medidas que aseguran perjudicarán
gravemente a la economía informe de
aurora abajo
en medio de un rápido aumento de nuevas
infecciones cientos de peruanos se
tomaron las calles de lima este jueves
para protestar contra las nuevas medidas
restrictivas anunciadas por el gobierno
el presidente interino francisco sagasti
anunció el martes el cierre total de la
capital y de otras 9 regiones a partir
del próximo lunes para evitar un
desborde del sistema sanitario medidas
rechazadas por un amplio sector de la
ciudadanía que teme un impacto demasiado
profundo para la economía
otros denuncian una conspiración
internacional para afectar al país
el gobierno provenientes a directivas
internacionales que se imponen a nivel
mundial es de suprimir la libertad
que los propósitos que tienen estás
cuarentenas es quebrar la economía no
solamente de este país sino de todos los
países para hacer un reseteo mundial
pero con más de 40 mil muertes es uno de
los países más golpeados de la región y
ahora hace frente a una nueva oleada de
contagios que tiene a los sistemas
hospitalarios al límite pero al límite
está también la economía que cayó un
11.6 por ciento en 2020 y se espera que
la vacunación no empiece hasta febrero
el programa de vacunación de israel ha
sido reconocido como uno de los más
eficientes del mundo al menos un tercio
de la población ya recibió la primera
dosis y ahora vacuna a mayores de 35
años pero el plan ha estado generando
polémica por dejar fuera a los
habitantes de los territorios palestinos
ocupados
israel avanza en su agresivo plan de
inmunización de la población allí las
personas mayores de 35 años podrán
recibir la primera dosis del fármaco
contra el coi 19 con ello las
autoridades del país esperan cumplir con
la meta de vacunar a una gran parte de
la población antes de la primavera
y en las noticias que hay permiso para
que las personas mayores de 35 años
vengan y se vacunen abrir la aplicación
y pedir la cita por suerte había para
hoy y no para mañana me apresuré y pedí
la segunda cita automáticamente y me
capacita a todos en el madrid pero
mientras que israel avanza para contener
la propagación del virus
la vacuna todavía no llega a los
palestinos en los territorios ocupados
de cisjordania y gaza en ramala la
capital de cisjordania los hospitales
experimentan un repunte en el número de
contagios la autoridad palestina lucha
para asegurar el suministro de la vacuna
rusa sputnik
y hay voces que instan a israel a
compartir sus vacunas
los israelíes han tenido un plan exitoso
de vacunación sin embargo los palestinos
no cuándo
miras la conexión entre palestinos e
israelíes no puedes vacunar a una parte
de la población y no a la otra y pensar
que estarás a salvo en el vice la onu ha
instado israel para que contribuye en la
respuesta a las necesidades del pueblo
palestino en los territorios ocupados
mientras los palestinos están sin
vacunas casi 2,8 millones de israelíes
han recibido la primera dosis y la mitad
de ellos una segunda
en eeuu el país con mayor cantidad de
dosis administradas en el mundo con más
de 24 millones de inyecciones la casa
blanca informó que el gobierno del
presidente joe biden garantizará que
todas las personas que se encuentren en
su país incluidos los migrantes
indocumentados tengan acceso a la vacuna
contra el cob y 19
como administración creemos que es
esencial asegurar que todas las personas
en eeuu los inmigrantes indocumentados
también por supuesto deben tener acceso
a una vacuna porque eso uno es
moralmente correcto pero también asegura
que la gente en el país esté a salvo
seif una coordinación de los inversores
minoristas expuso las debilidades de
wall street las redes sociales
facilitaron que inversores aficionados
dieran un golpe a través de una
aplicación robin hood la app para operar
en la bolsa sin mínimos ni comisiones se
convirtió en el instrumento para que
miles de personas comprarán acciones de
empresas como gamestop que disparó el
precio de sus acciones y ante estas
subidas frenética se anunciaron
restricciones para los pequeños
inversores un trato calificado de
injusto e inaceptable por algunos
congresistas estadounidenses
la batalla entre main street y wall
street' se ha extendido a las
plataformas comerciales en línea uno de
los más populares robin hood ha
provocado críticas entre sus clientes
después de restringir la compra de
acciones de gamestop y varias otras
empresas se llaman en robin hood verdad
así que si es un poco irónico que estén
allí ayudando a los grandes sabes fondos
de cobertura tienen una gran
participación en robin hood y ellos
pueden decirles que hacer eso no está
bien nos están afectando y estamos
enojados la decisión de robin hood se
produce después de que las
microtransacciones de gamestop hayan
provocado que sus acciones subieran más
del 700 por ciento durante la semana
pasada
usando acciones de foros en línea como
wall street' beats en red y un ejército
de inversores aficionados se ha unido
enfrentándose a enormes fondos de
cobertura que habían apostado en grande
contra gamestop aficionados tal vez pero
lograron infligir pérdidas que ascienden
a miles de millones de dólares a varios
grandes nombres de what's it si bien la
volatilidad ha atraído la atención de
los reguladores preocupados por la
manipulación del mercado algunos
analistas dicen que los pequeños
inversores están siendo tratados
injustamente
los traders minoristas en reddit no son
responsables por las mayores
manipulaciones del mercado ellos no son
quienes han recibido un billón de
dólares en rescates podrían estar detrás
de algunas distorsiones en algunas
operaciones pero si se cree que ahí es
donde está la acción principal de este
negocio no lo conoce muy bien algunos
miembros del congreso están pidiendo
ahora una investigación sobre las
prácticas del mercado de valores
y dejamos el continente americano china
anunció que a partir del 31 de enero no
reconocerá el llamado pasaporte
británico de ultramar como un documento
de viaje válido con este visado los
residentes de hong kong podrán a partir
de la misma fecha solicitar visas para
trabajar y vivir en reino unido- y
eventualmente aplicar a la ciudadanía
esta acción invade de manera severa la
soberanía de china e interfiere con los
asuntos internos de china en hong kong y
viola de manera severa las leyes
internacionales y los principios de las
relaciones internacionales
shanghai china se opone firmemente a
esto y expresa su indignación desde el
31 de enero china no reconocerá los
pasaportes bn o como un documento válido
de viaje o identidad sobe y finalizamos
con nuestra serie france24 ha dedicado
un espacio a la solidaridad con los
estudiantes uno de los sectores de la
sociedad francesa más tocados por la
crisis del cobi 19 el aislamiento a raíz
de la suspensión de las clases
presenciales ha hecho caer a muchos en
depresión
en su mayoría extranjeros se enfrentan a
graves dificultades económicas ante la
escasez de los trabajos de medio tiempo
que les permitían vivir y estudiar
reportaje en parís de erika olavarría
christophe dan set y nasri vence buzzi
no no
se consideran una generación sacrificada
es tercera vez que los estudiantes
franceses marchan este mes de enero
antes de la crisis del cód y muchos
financiaban su vida universitaria con
pequeños trabajos pero hoy no hay casi
ofertas lo buscaba en un cinema porque
estudió cine pero las salas están
cerradas y si no trabajo en tiendas
disimulo donde me pero no podemos ya que
cierran temprano a causa del toque de
queda jugó se lee un cambio teme al
fantasma de un tercer confinamiento la
biblioteca universitaria en la que
trabaja no le paga si está cerrada a
nosotros nos pagan por hora trabajada si
no hacemos nuestras horas no hay salario
si hay un nuevo confinamiento la
biblioteca cerrará nuevamente estaremos
en una situación muy difícil la falta de
ofertas de trabajo también la sintió
esta startup especializada en poner en
contacto a empresas y estudiantes
y éramos muy buenos en marketing de
calle y de repente ya no distribuimos
más publicidad hacíamos degustación de
productos en las tiendas hoy ya no
hacemos tampoco hay eventos pero poco a
poco nos adaptamos a las áreas de
trabajo que se han ido reactivando los
centros comerciales y negocios han
reabierto y eso fue como una bomba de
oxígeno pero exigente otra parte de las
demandas de la startup vino de las
farmacias
rafa estudiante tunecina curso tercer
año de medicina
la empresa encontró un trabajo haciendo
test de antígenos que se adapta
perfectamente a sus estudios
me proponen un trabajo y yo soy libre de
aceptar o rechazar la propuesta
[Música]
cuando los test en farmacia comenzaron
yo aproveché la ocasión
la joven empresa realizó también una
encuesta entre los 150.000 estudiantes
de su base de datos un 65% reconoció
estar viviendo graves dificultades
financieras
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía los
invitamos a seguir con más noticias y al
momento en france 24 puntocom y también
aquí en nuestra señal televisiva que
disfrute mucho de su día y cuídese y
mucho también del cobi 19
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital una
inmersión en profundidad en lo bueno lo
mal